I was going to read through them using
sudo Atticus that's true vanishing the
number of pH sets of the deal is
cardinality thank you very much to
everyone for being here thank you very
much for the to the organizers for
inviting me and let me letting me speak
right so i will talk about the number of
bh sets of a given size and so let's
start with the definition just make sure
so bh sets and sit on sets so suppose
you have a set a of natural numbers and
h is some fixed number h doing the stock
will this or is some fixed number fixed
integer and so a is a bh set if you do
if you do the following so you take all
hy sums of elements of a so a1 plus a2
aah a 1-up aah members of a so you can
you you you produce all these hy sons
and and if it so happens that they're
all distinct then you say that they set
a is a bh set in the case of h equals to
this was introduced by Sid on so they
are known as seed on sets okay so the
aim of the talk is to count these bh
sets so i would like to know how much
how many bh sets there are in brackets n
so the sets a from the previous slide
must be subsets of this bracket same and
again this is asymptotic H is fixed and
n goes to infinity right and the basic
tool that we use to do this is we
translate very roughly speaking we
translate the problem somehow at some
point to county independent sets in
locally dense graphs so these graphs are
kind of quasi random or at least from
below so you know that smaller sets have
at least some
entity so this is the main tool that one
uses and this is joint work so we have
been doing this first for each of us to
and then H equals 3 and so on so we have
been doing this with domingos della
Monica Sen John Dee vital role and
vertex some OT ok so that's the aim and
but let me start first with the with an
Associated extremal problem so that is
the following so again brackets n
numbers 1 to n let's first ask how big a
BH set can be you should take it from
brackets n so if this function f H of n
is a naturally associated function
extreme or combinatorial function is the
maximum size of acid on over bh set
contained in brackets in right so that's
F H of n max of size of a a contagion
end and bh set ok so for the case H
equals 2 as I mentioned before sit on
explicitly ask the question to estimate
fh of N and so let me give a very simple
argument that shows that F H of n is at
most n t1 / H you just do the following
so remember to be a bh set you have to
take the hy sons of elements of curly a
right so sums of the form a 1 plus a 2
and so on up to aah ok how many sons can
you produce that way you can produce
roughly kind of size of a choose H
because you have to select from your set
ok since your level repetition you
actually get this size of a plus h minus
1 choose H but it's roughly a choose H
and all these sums live in between the
numbers from 1 to hm right or h 2 h n so
you have this inequality here you have
that h is h roughly HOH is at most hn
because if all these hy sums have to be
distinct and they live in this universe
of size h n so we have this inequality
then if you come
dude a little bit you see that a is of
size at most n to the 1 over H with some
coefficient which it depends on age you
can get something like 2h if you like so
we get this upper bound for fh n which
is of the form into the 11 / h so that's
this inequality for right so continuing
a little bit so for lower bounds for
this extremal function bosing chawla
have some algebraic construction gave an
algebraic construction which gives n to
the 1 over H for this function with
coefficient 1 over 1 plus little Oh 14 h
equals 2 u.we you actually know that
this coefficient is 1 plus little one or
you even know a little bit more than
that but in general for H bigger than to
you just know that it's of order n to
the 1 over H and the coefficient is not
precisely known and for the upper bound
the best bounds are due to bend green
but actually I will not go into this
direction I will i'm interested in
counting this set so let me not talk too
much about this coefficient let me talk
about the counting problem the main
problem I'm interested in right now ok
so we would like to count how many sets
curly a we have inside the brackets in
that rbh sets so this will be the number
ZN h actually this question the question
of estimating sedan that n of h was
posed by cameron and a dish in the case
h equals 2 so this is the paper in which
kind of they talk about such counting
problems they talked about several
additive conditions for the set a and
they address the problem of counting
such sets and so here's the little
section in which they talk about Sid on
sets so sit on sets again so H equals 2
so the pair wise sons are distinct and
that's what's written in in parentheses
there ok and they they argue
since you know the f2 of and the
extremal function is root n you get
these lower end up upper bounds that you
can see here so 2 to the root n from for
the lower bound and end to the root end
for the upper bound so you have this
login in the exponent gap and they ask
yeah so watch what is the what should be
the answer to this but should be close
to the truth so again fh of n is this
extremal function the maximum size then
it's clear that two to the FN f H of n
is a lower bound for the number of bh
sets because you fix a bh set every
subset of this bh set is a [ __ ] that
also so that means that if you have a bh
set of size F H n then every subset
gives you two to the fh n obviously so
that's a lower bound for this for the
number of bh sets the trigger lower
bound comes everything comes from just
one fixed maximal maximum size gauge set
and also kind of trivially you know that
ZN of H can be bounded by all subsets of
size at most effing eff n of h and so
these so these two bounds give if you
recall that F H of n is of order n to
the 1 over H you get the following two
bounds dead end of Ages at least 2 to
the N n to the 1 over H and from above
you get n raised to the same power of
different coefficient or if you like to
to the constant times n to the 1 over H
and log in so that's 10 right to have
this login gap in the exponent with this
simple argument ok in fact we can prove
that the log in which you saw in the
exponent in the upper bound is not
necessary so one can prove that that can
be removed so that's the first
here and so yeah I'm just I'm just
reminding that I this just to remind me
that i should say again so that we have
we had to have these to bounce right
with the login gap in the exponent and
the answer is closer to the bottom side
of the trivial construction in which you
take one bh set in all subsets but of
course the coefficients in the exponent
that are all different and so on but at
least the order of the exponent is n to
the 1 over H okay and now let's consider
H goes to let's talk about lower bound
and it's a little bit surprising that
the app the lower bound is not of type 2
to the 1 plus little 1 f 2 of n it's
actually it's of that form but with
coefficient not one but this coefficient
1.16 at least this is a little bit
surprising because for instance i mean
there are such problems in the case of
graphs may be the oldest result is the
following so you could ask how many
grafts are there that are triangle free
okay this from the mid-70s we know that
the number of such graphs is something
like 2 to the N squared over 4 and that
you obtained by doing the following so I
have a graph on n vertices i'm
interested in triangle free graph so one
thing you could do is to take a balanced
bipartite graph n over 2 and over 2 and
they call subset of the edges right so
that would give you
so so here I'm talking you can take any
subset of edges here that gives you a
lower bound like this of the number of
triangle free graphs on n vertices and
in fact this is the right answer and
this is known since mid in the mid 70s
so it's a little bit surprising that in
the case of these sit on sets you don't
get the coefficient one in the exponent
you don't get the coefficient one in the
exponent you get one point something
bigger than one strictly bigger than one
and this comes from some some kind of
blow up construction or okay but let me
not discuss that mmm ok so I'm talking
about upper bounds yeah I will I'm
actually interested in a slightly more
refined version of this counting problem
namely i would like to count not all bh
sets containing brackets n but i would
like the number of bh sets of a given
size so now we have a new parameter
parameter T and have this new functions
en of ZN h t which is the number of bh
sets contained in brackets n of size t
that's 14 right so I'm interested in
estimating this and I I'm interested in
estimating this for a wide range of T ok
so so so this is so what what can we say
from below at least or let's try to get
some feeling about the numbers that will
show up so the first thing is so again H
is fixed
they're equal to let's talk about tea
which is not so big so T so in these
Roman one so T is at most epsilon times
n to the 1 over 2 h minus 1 this is X
this exponent of n is 1 over 2 h minus
one will show up kind of a quite a bit
now this is kind of some critical point
or critical exponent for this for this
thing okay so in this Roman 1 i'm
interested in the case in which t is not
so big it is epsilon times this power of
n okay in that case the number of bh
sets is 1 minus delta T times n choose t
of course interest is all you could have
in a fraction of 1 minus Delta the T of
them are actually bh sets so again what
is the quantification you can specify
any Delta then if you make epsilon small
enough in the bound for t you get this
kind of 1 minus del to the T fraction as
bh sets okay so it's a small fraction is
exponentially small but you can make the
base of the exponent as as close to one
as you like but then to do that you have
to pay by making tea small in comparison
with this into the one over 2h minus one
okay so that's the is the first remarks
the secondary mark is that ok so you can
ask what happens if you make tea a
little bit bigger so maybe you're
interested in t equal to 10 times n to
the 1 over 2h minus 1 and actually we
can go up to four this Roman to hear I
will save the lower bond in a moment you
can go even some poly log factor above
this power of n ok and the Bandit that
you get is again some fraction of an
inch of T fraction of the universe and
this fraction is this e to the minus 4
something to the T so previously I had
some number close to one to the t now I
have some number which goes to zero to
the T and yeah if you look at a little
bit at this exponential what's inside
this exponential it starts correctly I
mean it matches 14 and 15 match when you
talk about constant times n to the 1
over 2h minus 1 because if you kind of
put t go to constant and this power of n
the ends cancel and you get some
constant right but as you make tea
bigger or the constant bigger this
exponential the base of this exponential
goes to 0 right up to the point in which
so we are allowed to take T some poly
log times the power of n so you even get
some power of in as a base of this
exponential in this lower bound so your
oil so again as you make tea bigger this
lower bound gets worse and worse right
and that's what we have for lower back
let me just very briefly try to say why
you have such lower bounds I will talk
about Roman one so i will talk about the
case in which t is quite small so
epsilon times this critical power of n
so here's a rough sketch of the proof ok
we want to bound the number of key
element bh sets from below and we start
with the following simple remark suppose
mm is a new number so suppose M is a lot
smaller than n to the 1 over 2h minus 1
this critical power of n actually and
then do the following consider random
sets of M elements taken from brackets
in a completely random uniformly at
random now this power of n this n to the
1 over 2h minus 1 is chosen in such a
way that if you do this you can look
into your random set and you can count
how many forbidden things you have
what is forbidden forbidden well you we
are forbidden hy sums that have the same
some right to different hy sums that
give you the same result ok so you can
count those and in such a spare set you
don't have many of them actually with
probability with high probability such
as set random set brackets in M can be
turned into a bh set by deleting just a
few elements a few elements I mean a
small fraction of em so okay you can
remove some type T which is little om so
this random set random em element set is
kind of essentially all of it is bh set
the numbers work out that way now now
it's now you do it the following
remember we are trying to bound this znh
t so you make em a little bit bigger
than T and you apply this observation
and you do the following account every
em element set is essentially bh bh set
so for every random set you have one bh
set but then when you do this you have
lots of double counting because two
different random sets maybe have large
intersection and they have the same
contribute the same pH set in your
counting so you have to discount this
counting so there is yeah you divide the
binomial coefficient and so and then you
apply some elementary binary identity so
you get this double counting thing gives
you a factor I mean you have to divide
by some inch you have to divide n choose
t by m choose t and m is just a little
bigger than T so it's 1 plus epsilon
times T so this this binomial
coefficient is is some exponential in
tea with the base which is very close to
1 so that gives you the lower bound ok
so this gives some feeling at least why
you have this critical point into the
one over 2h minus 1 and y you can get
this menu at least one below this range
ok now this fact three had a second
second thing right so I I said we could
you can make tea a little bit bigger and
then you get this other bound and to do
that you actually you do something
slightly more complicated to getting to
get the bh set given some random em set
and i will skip this i will just mention
that you use uncrowded hypergraphs
independent sets in uncrowded
hypergraphs actually yeah actually it
was the referee who kind of noticed that
we say something which was a little bit
incompatible with this fact 32 and the
referee said yeah so maybe you should
look at some old paper in which you use
uncrowded hypergraphs to do this and
there was actually some paper in which
we use this kind of method to obtain
large c for free graphs inside random
drops but let let me carry on let me not
kind of discuss this so so far I only
spoke about lower bounds so you have
some idea about what kind of numbers you
get and here is finally the theorem what
we can prove so again H is fixed and we
have some small epsilon fixed then if T
is big so I so far I only spoke about
teas which were below or just a little
bit above this critical power of n above
by some log poly log factor but now I'm
putting I'm putting some extra asylum in
the exponent now that's the kind of tea
we can talk about in this theorem and
the bound is like this is this in over T
to the H minus epsilon to the T
okay we should compare it with the lower
bounds to have some feeling what kind of
18 means so again so here is the upper
bound written in a slightly different
way I'm just I just factored out and
choose t so that we can compare it with
a lower bound ok so it's n choose t
times some exponential in t some
quantity exponentially decreasing with t
but actually the base of the exponential
has a tea in the bottom so it really
goes to 0 fast and remember that when T
is below this critical power of n n to
the 1 over 2h minus 1 then you actually
had some exponential reduction but the
base was very close to 1 so this is the
kind of 19 and 20 kind of show you the
gap that you have before and after T
crosses this critical power of n n to
the 1 over 2h minus 1 so yeah probably
it's not necessary but we can say this
in the following way you suppose you
have n choose t or and you select a
random set of size t out of all possible
sets and you can ask yourself the
probability that you will sample our bh
set and the probability the probability
that this happens changes really quite
suddenly suddenly in the sense that yeah
so you have these two bounds 40 right
and there's a dramatic change because in
one case the probability is kind of some
number close to one to the T in in the
other case yeah so in the end in the
other case is T to the minus T to the
minus T so there is some kind of change
of behavior at this point
okay and the actually when we were at
the beginning of this project we were
interested in some actually some
different problem and I will talk about
very briefly about this other problem
wherein we were interested in the
following take a typical subset of
brackets n so and we were interested in
knowing how bigger bh set you can find
inside of this random set so let me say
it again so a typical subset of brackets
n I will fix the cardinality now this is
going to be M so I consider all inches
mm element subsets of brackets n choose
one uniform that random write this
brackets n index m means sub M means
such a random set and i'm interested in
filing inside this bracket NM th set of
maximum size so I what I want to know
that what kind of size you can find
inside brackets n n so that's the
extremal function f of age brackets NM
we were interested in this function
actually this is a random variable of
course because brackets NM is a random
object and of course if n equals n F H
of n is yeah so that you recover the
original extreme of function f H of n
and so the first easy remark which we
already actually used is that if M is
below this critical quantity into the
one over 2h minus 1 then most of it is a
th set so this external function is kind
of closed closed as big as it could be
so it's one Minds little 0 1 times n and
and then the point is that if you go
above this critical power of in
something this they should change
and in fact the famous theorems by
Cullinan GAO's and shot the transference
theorems it actually tells you that this
function f hn of em is little n above
this critical power of n and we were
actually interested in saying something
about this function and here's what we
can say because of these using these
counting results so now to say the
result I need to introduce some let's
start from the beginning so again H is
fixed and I have some piecewise linear
function bh of a so the function is this
let me show you the graph of this
piecewise in a function it's here so
it's a piecewise linear function with
this three three bits and this one over
2h minus one is the exponent of n that
showed up quite a quite a lot so far
yeah okay so that's the piecewise linear
function here it is now we do the
following so the theorem is fix some
parameter a and consider em to be into
the a-plus little 1a is any number
between 0 and 1 right but fixed and now
I mean I'm interested in looking at
random sets of size n and msn to the a
how bigger bh said can you find in such
a random set okay the answer is you get
bh set of size n to the BHA and bha is
this piecewise linear function from 24
so let me say it using the graph so we
have a random set of into the a elements
so in this graph it would be like this
it would be kind of the diagonal right
your random set just goes up as a
increases right and the size of the
largest bh set inside it goes along with
a diagonal with the size of the set up
to this critical power of n n to the 1
over 2 h minus 1 and then it kind of
stabilizes
stays flat up to this second critical
exponent of n and then it kind of grows
and but it doesn't grow at a rate 1 it
grows kind of yeah a trait one over H so
this is the behavior of of this extremal
function on this random set it kind of
goes up then flattened and goes yeah
this was kind of the reason why we were
interested in we found this problem
interesting okay yeah so I'm out of time
and I I will only say I didn't say I
said that we get this we do this
counting by using by counting dependent
sets and graphs let me just say what the
graph is have a little bit quicker sorry
I bit quickly so we want to estimate
this this ZN HT right and t this big so
the strategy is as follows you we start
with some set s s is a bh set and s is
big smaller than T and then we ask
ourselves in how many ways we can
increase s to a tee element bh set by
adding some set s prime to s and to do
that well as the starting set the seed
set has size like comparable to n to the
1 over 2 h minus 1 but then we do the
following we consider hy son so we
consider 2 h minus 2 elements 0 a 1 up
to 81 and then be one up to be h minus 1
from the set s so they're already there
in the set s and then now we consider
two elements x and y and if so happens
that you have this identity you have
this 26 then you cannot put both x and y
into your set s or into your set s prime
which you are with
you are hoping to add 2 s to obtain a bh
set so one excludes the other so you can
just draw a graph joining x and y and
then you can search for independent sets
in this graph and the independence that
will not let you put both x and y into
the set X prime so that's where the
graph kind of shows up now I will I
don't know I shouldn't try to say much
about this I should perhaps just say
yeah so so with this notion that one l1
x 4 bits and why is encoded as a graph
problem in this graph is actually for H
equals to this graph is locally then you
can show that any not too small set has
enough edges so that the independent
sets there aren't that there cannot be
too many independent set so the graph is
a lower regular or pseudo-random at
least from below but then for H equals 3
or bigger ages it's a lot Messier the
graph is not another yeah anyway I will
not try to say more than that actually
so I just skip to the end because in the
end I have a I have a thank you slide
[Applause]
they said any questions thankfully so
you see the progression of course in the
integers that's the same question when
you have vector spaces of them for the
Aged sounds are different then you get
some open questions in coding theory if
you look haha no I haven't at all just
that if I mean the question of which one
is typing the fecking bundled mm-hmm
seems that you get the bacon bomb start
right and you're right and put a end so
you consider into the Dior's en tu dors
LP to the D or something like that and
thank you no I didn't write uh-huh when
you come to count the number independent
sets in your bra yeah right okay so yeah
so there are slides about containers but
we cannot use containers I mean the
hypergraph containers we use just a
graph case somehow this problem seems to
be there is something different or yeah
so we cannot use containers directly we
really have to mess around with a graph
right
actually I wanted an obsessive so this
beautiful result of illusion every set
of size M ran the integers has this
subset of size n to the 1 over H which
is a VHS anything so presumably that
function is kind of lower than your eh
eh ah sorry like me so I didn't i
scrapped yeah so the graph aha right
yeah actually yeah right so our purposes
that's that's correct so we can use what
you just said for this bit here yeah
right I'm sorry oh this is just to show
that the slope is oh I see you mean yeah
so it's yeah maybe that's Russia okay
okay any more questions no there's one
more so could you comment why there is
this flat part where it comes from
because of the car no I mean no because
right so no it'sit's entrance on the
beginning is just random right that
there is this pilot cryptic flat and
sensor is this obvious from one over age
so I wonder what is it the character of
this flat part yes I mean the lower
bound mmm
so for the lower bound I suppose if
you're just interested in these yeah
right okay so for the lower bound maybe
you can say in a random hypergraph you
know the size of the largest independent
set right so torrents theorem or
something like that for hypergraphs that
gives you the lower bound right but the
fact that the you have a matching upper
bound maybe it's maybe says that when
your size n is in that range I know
that's that's what it is it's random and
above after this second critical point
your said must have some more structure
or something like that I don't really
know if you mean Turan and a to H or
write write something like that yeah
actually for H equals 2 we even computed
more so we even know there's some power
poly log factor on top of this into the
BHA so this little one you can even
write some poly log thing and then you
can use this uncrowded hydrographs and
so on and they at least for ichigo's do
they match of the constant which is
the normal questions let's thank the
thank you very much